Hey guys how's it going? I've got some pretty somber
news and I'll just get straight to the point
my childhood dog, Buddi, who you guys have
probably seen in pictures and in
videos I've posted on the channel, -uhh-
passed away yesterday morning and -um-
it's heartbreaking in of itself you know
it's not quite the same as losing a family member but to me that dog was family.
Like we raised that dog since
she was *this* big. I mean the reason
her name is Buddi is because, when we first got her,
we thought that she was a boy
and -uhh- we only learned later
that -uhh- she was not -ha. And so basically
we had already been calling her "buddy", so we changed the
Buddy with a "y" to a Buddi with an "i".
And so ,when I- when I was really growing up
-like- ever since from Junior High to
-like- now, Buddi was
the sweetest dog
-like- the goodest girl to ever exist.
And -you know- I-I've
shed my tears I've talked to my family,
but was is even more heartbreaking about it is
-like- I've been spam recording the past two weeks for
this trip that I was going to take tomorrow.
I was going to drive all the way back to Cincinnati,
with Chica in the car so that Chica and Buddi could
meet.
And sad to say
-like- I missed my chance on that one.
And that
just sucks.
It sucks for multiple reasons because, number one,
it wasn't able to happen, even though I know
that they would've been best of friends, I know that
for a fact. They are super sweet goldens
from opposite ends of the world but I know
that they would've been the best of friends,
but what sucks even more is knowing
that I had so many opportunities to make that happen.
I've had Chica for just about 2 years now;
over 2 years now I've had Chica.
And in those 2 years, from the very first day I got her,
I wanted her to meet Buddi.
And I didn't make that happen.
And I know I can't blame myself an- and letting it
eating me up inside, and I don't, I'm no-
I'm not letting it -like-
spiral me down into depression, but it got me thinking about
-like- opportunities that just pass you by
because you think it can wait. You know, I don't have a- I don't have a
a big sweeping life lesson to learn about this;
I don't have a -like- a big sweeping -like-change, I'm like "dah I learned
this lesson so X on the channel is gonna change forever,
and that's a Markiplier promise", it's -um-
I'm no- I'm not anything about that, but what I did
learn was that -you know-
it's very easy to make excuses to...
push back the things that are important, but seem
like they can wait -you know- I remember so many times that
I would talk to my friends or family back in Cincinnati and I'd be like
"oh yeah yeah yeah I'll come back next month. I'll come back next month." and the month
would roll up and I'd go like "Oh you know I got busy this
month I'll make sure next month I promise next month."
and it's like it's super easy
to get caught up in that cycle and even though you know
Me I did plan to come this month I wanted to come back for Christmas
and I am still doing it and I prepared for it
and I made videos for it because I managed my time well and I did
everything right
but still was just a little
bit too late
and you never know when that opportunity is going to come you know
you can't beat yourself up because it happened this one time and you can't
eat yourself up because "oh if only
I'd done 'X' more" you know it's
it's just important to see the things that are important right
now
And to identify the things that actually
can wait
and not push the things that are the most important
into the waiting column because you never know when they are gone
You never know
Like it could be tomorrow it could be a year from now.
Like why take that risk. Tell the people who are
important to you that they are important to you now.
Tell the people that you love that you love them today
See those members of your family including
dogs that left such an impression on you
through your whole life
you know see them more
See them with the same intensity that a dog
Sees you when you've
come back from a trip because I
ah shit, I remember every single time
I came back to my step-mom's house
it was the house that I kind of grew up in
but you know the longer I've been away the less
it feels like home. But when I come back
and I open that door and
Buddi was there just wagging her
tail to no end just as soon she could tell it was me
she just exploded with joy every single time
and...
That's what I'm gonna remember you know
that's what I'm gonna remember
and you know I may not be able to ever see that again
out of Buddi..
But I see that with Chica and I think Chica spreads that same joy
in a different way you know you can't ever replace it but
Chica has that joy and i want to make sure I give her
the most joy that she can ever have in her life because Buddi
never had a bad day in her life
Like it's something that my step-mom always says "Buddi never had a bad day
in her entire life." Everyday
was filled with happiness, sunshine, and love
and you know
I think that's something to be
Something to be learned from
So anyway I've provided down in the description
a few videos that Buddi has been in from the
very first one where I actually announced a livestream
with her and to a few more that I was just doing
update vlogs from when i was back home
and i don't know just
if you guys want to check them out they are done in the description below
as like I said I'm going on Christmas break but that doesn't mean the videos are going to stop
I have a bunch of videos recorded
and i'm gonna be recording more today and i'm gonna be  struning them about
about all through Christmas I'm gonna be recording stuff
while I'm at home I'm gonna be making videos because it's fun to make videos
and I'm going to be prioritizing
time with my family
and then immediately after that we are going on tour so
if you guys haven't seen yet
we are going on tour again we got shows
they are all listed in the description below we are doing
the U.S. in January and in February we are doing Europe
So check down there
for all the shows I don't know if I'm gonna be doing this tour
again after these shows so these might be the last time we go out
um just ah
thank you everybody that has seen it and
thank you everybody that has supported it and um its going to be okay
cause I know I'm not perfect
and I don't try to be and you know I don't try to make these videos
as some testament to how wonderful
a human being I am you know
But I learn things from these things
these moments in my life I learn
and I try to take the best parts of it
not let the worst part bog me down because
you know I'm not perfect
But I try to be a little bit better everyday
and hopefully that's going to get me somewhere
and if it doesn't oh well as long as I got the right
things in mind and what's really important in my heart
you know I think I'll make it through it okay
So thank you everybody so much for watching I've got some late minute stuff to record
I'm gonna be doing the new resident evil DLC today.
I'm gonna be finishing up Doki Doki Literature Club, I've been recording it
I just haven't been posting it um and then um I'm going to...
Drive for about three days straight back to Cincinnati
Thank you everybody so much for watching look forward to some cool stuff
coming at you real soon. And as always
I'll see you in the next video
Bye-Bye!